I'm on a great escape to Cambodia
there's a food revival underway as a
country rediscovers the traditional
cooking that was lost during the years
of famine under the Khmer Rouge rule
I've received a royal summons to cook an
old-style Cambodian dinner at the end of
the week some going cross country to
scour the land for dishes that are
worthy of this great honor
Luther Heywood eyes are getting around
Cambodia's backroads
will take more than a sat-nav so I've
hired local driver Luther maybe not so
close to the truck and we can see the
whiskers on the driver okay
access first stop on my foodie Safari is
to try one of Cambodia's favorite street
foods and booth or knows where they
serve the best is the maybe dad ate
there one don't we your photo duck
exists
hello yeah and what's so special about
the duck eggs making man have power and
it's good for your sex life la bufa
ducking everyday power you Randy little
bastard unbelievable rice we try them
duck egg viagra this I've got to see
Saad pepper lm1 Jesus it's like we're
doing jokela shots I've had duck eggs
before but I can't wait to find out what
makes these so special
oh please beyond what is still good
we've got the body in their native on
the India
I can't believe booth wants me to eat an
unborn baby duck and then Ewing that yes
polishing are you [ __ ] crazy another
crazy animal be bothered that that's
good for your sex life yeah hasty
it's nice fresh how old was that Rajini
20 days
actually tastes better than it looks
yeah it looks disgusting but actually
tastes by nice anything happening
downstairs Oh pecker yeah yeah yeah yeah
everyone let on this is a real insight
it was easier to swallow than it looked
I'm looking forward to what booth er has
in store for me next